any movies out now you want to go and
watch go on
i want to watch what's what's out in
cinemas right now
that's that's the one i want to watch
that's pretty much the only thing that
i've been hyped about um i want to watch
shangshi i guess one's like coming out
on like blu-ray like
i don't know it's probably might be
already out and dude is it already on
dvd guys you still buy blu-rays no
because like when it's out on blu-ray
that's when it's out
in to the public that's how like my my
mind [ __ ] works i guess i like i it's
rare for me to go to a cinema to watch a
movie because that means i better be
hyped for this [ __ ] movie
about it
yeah what other movies are coming out
this like this i still want to go see
belle normally the holiday period has a
lot of stuff coming out yeah the new
kingsman movie coming in oh yeah yeah
yeah
i kind of want to watch that
king kingsman is definitely uh i can
watch this at home kind of right now i'm
i'm not going out my way to watch
kingsman i want to see the new matrix
movie whenever that comes oh i'm
watching that in cinemas i'm watching
i'm watching that and since all i really
know when is the next john wick movie
coming out that's what i want to know
is it actually soon uh oh wait sorry i
think they're still filming so yeah it's
been like two years
come on i need it it takes time to make
a masterpiece i need it is it donny uh
what's his name
what he's he's he's in the new general
he is donnie yen yeah he's a yes he took
a selfie with catering what i love
donaire he's great
so when you go to a when you go to a
screening and it's like a hype screening
like the new avengers movie you'll hate
it when it's full
do you do you want do you think
if the crowd is hyped up and reacts to
it and says [ __ ] yeah i hate that i hate
that okay look i think we've established
this before in the podcast actually yeah
we've spoken about this before um
i hate going to a cinema where the crowd
is loud yeah yeah me too yeah like
we've definitely said this on an episode
yeah
yeah i said like i don't wanna i'm not
here to see a [ __ ] concert i'm here
to see it on a movie so it's like i
don't i hate it when people are like
whispering being like oh this is the
part where your [ __ ] comes i'm like shut
up shut like like when a hype scene
happens and like the the [ __ ] cinema
erupts
did you like it would you like when it
happens okay when it's like one okay
when it's like at the climax yeah it's
fine but like when they're non-stop
doing it yeah like shut the [ __ ] up okay
yeah but like if it's like okay yeah
like the cnn game when he gets the
[ __ ] hammer all right sure everyone
everyone everyone lost that [ __ ] all
right i hate it i wanted to be
completely silent i was annoyed at the
end game though because the guy next to
me would kept like he'd already seen it
yeah and so he was with someone okay and
he kept telling them you know you got
this possible to be sick and i'm like
we're in the movie shut the [ __ ] up let
him watch it yeah you're telling me i'm
right next to you shut up
what do you think's the best cinematic
experience you've had then john wick
three john with three
ship was amazing i loved watching that
in cinemas the cinema was empty i had a
great time it was beautiful i watched
like the last viewing of the day yeah it
was totally empty i got to like put my
feet up on the chair in front of me had
popcorn it's beautiful it was wonderful
i mean i said in the previous episode
but dune was [ __ ] amazing for me
yeah that was the best cinematic
cinematic experience you've ever heard
of recent time that i can remember yes
that was incredible honestly any any any
movie with like a han zimmer soundtrack
you don't hear the [ __ ] soundtrack
you [ __ ] you feel it all that [ __ ]
yeah holy [ __ ] that dolby digital audio
7.1 [ __ ] your pants experience
my god like when i went to go see
[ __ ] uh inception in cinemas
the first time you hear that like i
thought my colon was gonna explode from
how bassy that [ __ ] this man must like
edit on like [ __ ] ipod like
first generation headphones like no way
can a men listen to that much bass daily
like that can't be healthy and not be
dead yeah yeah yeah
you must listen to them through like
some shitty earphones we can barely hear
it oh [ __ ] it needs more bass i think at
this point he just he doesn't listen he
[ __ ] feels the bass
what if he like goes to the ceiling he's
like [ __ ] that's how much bass i put in
[ __ ] i didn't even realize i couldn't
hear it [ __ ] more bass
jesus christ
god the subwoofers on his life [ __ ]
speakers i can't imagine
i'd like to think he's just editing off
a laptop speaker or something
like garageband or something
he's a little more bass i think why hans
zimmer's house doesn't have any windows
imagine it your hands dimmer
imagine being han zimmer's neighbor [ __ ]
bro
he's just
[Music]
it's 2 am and all i hear is bass
actually there's an alien spaceship
docking outside there's so much bass
going on nope it's just bounce
imagine your hands hands man come on man
you know it's 3am our kids are going to
school tomorrow can you please stop we
understand you're making the soundtrack
to inception
but not right now this is retention come
on man this is too much man come on
please stop you imagine if han zimmer
was japanese my god his neighbors must
think that there is like a magnitude 6
earthquake every other day
was japanese be like uh i would like to
buy the entire building please
how much rent is that easy i got you how
does zuma has to live
like locate his house in a place where
seismographs cannot pick it up
because it will false positive
earthquakes otherwise
he'll like set off like an earthquake
warning every other day
or he's recording audio
and zimmer's testing out his new
subwoofer
it's terrible oh my god
oh my god it's [ __ ] amazing